[Musique]
sénateur, je suis chrétien, je comprends que vous
êtes chrétien, vous avez écrit une citation musulmane. Les
musulmans n'ont pas simplement une
théologie déficiente, ils ne connaissent pas Dieu parce qu'ils ont
rejeté Jésus-Christ, son fils, et
ils sont condamnés et le code,
croyez-vous, le fait-il ?  vous pensez que cette
déclaration est islamophobe, absolument pas
sénateur, je suis chrétien et je crois en
un ensemble de principes chrétiens basés sur
ma foi, croyez-vous que les personnes de
religion musulmane sont condamnées, alors je
vous le redis, sénateur, je suis chrétien
et j'ai bien écrit cet article, quelle est
vraiment la déclaration de foi, nous pourrions
comprendre que je ne sais pas combien de
musulmans il y a en Amérique, je
ne sais vraiment pas, probablement quelques millions,
suggérez-vous que tous ces
gens sont condamnés  qu'en est-il des Juifs,
ils sont condamnés - sénateur, je suis
chrétien, je comprends que vous êtes
chrétien mais ce pays est composé de
gens qui ne le sont pas seulement. Je comprends
que le christianisme est la
religion majoritaire mais il y a d'autres personnes de
religions différentes dans ce pays  et
partout dans le monde, à votre avis,
pensez-vous que les personnes qui ne sont pas
chrétiennes vont être condamnées,
merci d'avoir approfondi cette question en
tant que chrétien. Je crois que tous
les individus sont créés à l'image de Dieu
et sont dignes de dignité et de respect.
quelles que soient leurs croyances religieuses, je
dirais simplement mr.  le président que cette
comédie n'est vraiment pas quelqu'un qui est ce que
ce pays est censé être à propos de
la Bible, je ne sais pas